I'm joined by the shadow work and
pensions secretary Jonathan Ashworth
good morning
um
Nadim zahal he's just been saying uh
what is Labor's view about
Putin's intentions we we can't know he's
right to say that Britain is
unpredictable but do you think we need
to be prepared for the possibility that
he could use nuclear weapons well of
course we have to be prepared for all
eventualities that I'm not going to
speculate on the on the mind of uh of
Putin I'm not remotely in a position to
do so but clearly
we need to consider continue to support
Ukraine in every way that we can we need
to work internationally to ensure that
pressure is continually applied uh to
Putin's to Putin and of course yes we
have to be prepared but look I I I've
heard I've read uh experts it's pretty
serious I'm not I'm not downplaying it
remotely but it's not for me to
speculate on the on the psychology of
computing and what he may or may not do
but obviously we need to be prepared all
right let's let's deal with psychology
closer to home I know you study um
labor has said that it would not have
proposed the uh abolition 45p rate
um labor has said that it will keep the
1p uh off income tax if it comes to
power it will also keep the cap on
energy built and spend 2 billion pounds
on NHS staff you also support the
Investments proposed by the Tories and
skills on what they call supply side
um other than the windfall tax what
concrete measures would a labor
government take to deal with the
economic situation that the
conservatives have not taken well the
economic situation is perilous at the
moment because that budget three weeks
ago or so wasn't just a budget which
gave 45 billion pounds worth of unfunded
tax cuts disproportionately to the
better off in society because there was
no validation of the plans of that
budget by the independent obr it led to
turmoil on the markets it led to guilt
yields Rising it led to a run on Pension
funds and now mortgage costs are soaring
so people coming off off a mortgage and
this year about 1.8 million of them will
be doing that in the next 12 months or
so are facing a mortgage increase of
hundreds of pounds every every month as
a consequence so we are in a particular
perilous moment because of decisions
that were taken by Liz truss and quasi
quatang three weeks ago it's why we've
called for that kamikam budget to be
reversed because we need to build a
dynamic economy absolutely but we need
stability in our economy instead what
we've got is a reckless approach a spike
in borrowing costs and now the
government as we understand it are
talking about asking working mums and
dads disabled people poorer pensioners
to pay the price for that recklessness
if I may say so um Sky viewers know all
of that because we're reporting it all
the time once guys viewers have no idea
about is what you would do so let me ask
you again what would labor do other than
the windfall tax which would only last a
year what would labor do to tackle all
of the problems you've enumerated that
the conservatives are not now doing well
actually our party conference was two
weeks ago we outlined how we're going to
rebuild our economy make our economy
more Dynamic and spread prosperity and
opportunity for example we're going to
invest in the green technologies of the
future not only because well they're not
the problem is they're not are they if
they were
storage facilities they've criticized so
the panels in fields I mean I remember
they were refusing to go for off onshore
wind so they're not invested in the
green technology in the future it's easy
to go for offshore one shot on shot they
haven't made a decision no no come on no
no no no no no
you asked me a question I'm going to
give you another 30 seconds
to say about the Tories and then let's
come back later 30 seconds no I don't
want to tell us how bad the tour is I'm
not talking about the Tories I'm talking
about what labor are doing we're going
to invest in these green technologies
not only because that because in this
period of international instability how
much are you going to invest 28 billion
pounds okay Rachel Reeves told us that
uh she told me that actually about six
months ago okay so what's new about the
cost of living about inflation we're not
in a different situation you yourself
have just said that what we would you do
about this situation that Tories don't
do I'll tell you what we will do we're
going to reform our welfare system to
get people back to work the 600 000 over
50s have left the labor market since the
Pandemic those leaving the labor market
for reason of sickness is now rising at
its highest rate ever and is at a
20-year high and yet we don't have a job
center plus system or a welfare system
that is supporting these people to go
back into work many of them say they
will return to work if they're given the
correct support to do it and yet the
government are not giving those people
any support whatsoever now if you can
get people back to work that is a supply
side reform what does that support look
like what is it is it money well is it
advice what is it well some of it is to
do with advice and employment services
so for example if if you're in your 50s
and you've left the labor market it may
be that you are looking for a flexible
type of work it may be that you're
caring for grandchildren but also caring
for a loved one a mum or a dad or a
partner he might have that Dementia or
might have had a stroke and you're
looking for a flexible work option at
the moment you can't walk into the job
center and ask for help to find that job
for you so I want to reform the way job
sensors work I want to reform the way in
which we do Employment Services in this
country to get more people into work and
those who are currently on benefits in
low paid work I want to give them the
help so they can work more hours or move
into better paid jobs so actually we've
got a big program of Reform to our
social security system which will help
more people into work which is the type
of supply side reform that will actually
bring inflation down stabilize the cost
of living and grow our economy all right
look I mean we could carry on about that
I'm not sure I can still quite see the
difference here but let's talk there's a
big difference because the conservative
government aren't doing that okay and
there's a million vacancies in the
economy all I can tell you is that they
will sit here and tell me that they are
doing it but they won't I promise you
they won't absolutely
let's talk about something that is that
matters today and that is the s p have
their conference we are pretty sure that
they will um call for a second
independent referendum if labor we're in
government would it Grant the SNP a
second referendum no okay uh the
Scottish government let me ask you
another thing because
it it's it is thought unlikely that uh
that labor will get an outright majority
without looking at polls today that's
possible but let's see let's say uh that
the most like outcome here is that labor
would need some support from the SNP
um what are your relations like right
now on issues like for example the
gender recognition question uh the Scott
Scottish national party says that it
plans to make it legal for an individual
born with a typical male body to have
their gender change without any
professional assessment or medical
intervention
um that's what they want to do will
labor support that bill well hang on the
whole premise of your question was that
labor cannot form a majority now I'm not
one to pray in a opinion polls because I
believe the only opinion polls that
matter is the one on elections you told
me that before on Election Day but
um I'm afraid
um the premise of your question is that
labor won't get majority well the
opinion polls are not showing that at
the moment as indeed you did concede
when you asked me the question
absolutely so look look right we are
planning we are campaigning for and we
are hoping to win the trust of the
British people to form a majority labor
government so whatever the SMP policy is
here or there or everywhere is around
relevant we're going to form a majority
labor government in order to rebuild our
public services in order to get people
back to work and actually to support
people from these cost of living just to
come back to my specific question will
the Labor uh party in these Scottish
Parliament vote for this piece of
legislation
I mean I presume the the I mean I don't
know is the honest answer but I presume
my colleagues in the Scottish labor
party uh uh are broadly supportive of uh
uh of changes to support trans people
who are a very marginalized group in
society are very stigmatized weapon
society and have uh are often treated
but including male bodied people going
into women's refuges for example and
women's prisons well is that a specific
that's what the item is my colleagues in
the Scottish labor party in the
parliament will no doubt have opinions
on this and we'll we'll respond I mean
I'm not a member of the Scottish
Parliament all right John I swear thank
you very much indeed for your time this
morning